the Joe Rogan experience we were just
talking about caning and hanging in
Singapore hanging now is that the new
one no it's always caning is one of the
forms of capital punishment but they
still they actually hang for drugs
what is Singapore like I've never been
it seems like a strange place because
it's relatively wealthy right yes very
upscale and very nice but also ruthless
but you know what happened in like my
generation I've witnessed it go from
third world first of all in my lifetime
really yeah yeah so it's one of those
success stories of nation-building but
it's it's kind of like you know those
snow globes the perfect snow globes yeah
yeah when you like turn it over and like
everything kind of sprinkles that's what
it feels like living in Singapore for me
at least I I had to get out it's just
it's a bit sterile it's perfect but it's
too perfect it's almost like there's a
somebody called it once Disneyland with
the death penalty which is pretty good
and did you get the death penalty for
things like drugs right just possession
past like maybe 25 grams or 25
milligrams or something marijuana
trafficking so if you have an ounce of
marijuana how many grams is the
conversion I don't know I haven't
convert it to 20 your system 28 grams in
an ounce so like that an ounce is a good
amount of weed but two ounces of weed
you're dead yep yeah my hanging oh two
ounces wow that's that's weird you can
go down the street and buy that at a
store yeah
I you just have to show your driver's
license so you're over 21 and you can
buy that at a store and it's Singapore
they'll kill you for it
all right how many people have they
killed for pot I don't I don't know
about that but I do know like one time
they actually executed a Australian
citizen who was on transit so he didn't
even get all the airport he was just
kind of carrying the drugs on transit
when they found him oh yeah hanging it's
always hanging and what would do you
remember what kind of Joe it was he
selling drugs he he was carrying quite a
bit he was definitely trafficking it
Jesus Christ
yep zero zero tolerance policy yeah it's
great how did it go from third world to
first world so quickly
I guess the founder you know the country
well not the founder the founding prime
minister mr. Lee Kuan Yew is probably
one of the world's most famous modern
statesmen he he was resolute like you
know weeded out corruption he was kind
of like very very tight controls on free
speech but very much sort of neoliberal
economic policies so attracted a lot of
foreign investment right because the
highest income tax bracket is like maybe
13 percent it's very low there's almost
no welfare at least in in the sense of
how we understand welfare but there's a
lot of it's a hybrid system so there's
there's a lot of like zero capital gains
taxes zero state taxes very easy to set
up a business so he managed to attract a
lot of foreign businesses to set up
their multinational corporation
headquarters in Asia because the other
alternative would be maybe China mm-hmm
but China would probably end up stealing
all your you know your your corporate
secrets your intellectual property but
Singapore was billed as this is the
country that protects rule of law also
English he kind of made everybody speak
English was the working language so if
you want to do set up business in Asia
that was your place to go
you got a like you know if you if you
want to try investment you say like okay
what's in mine
what's in my region and how can I be how
can I have a competitive advantage so
that was that was how Singapore really
developed thing and you know just gained
a lot of traction as a state the average
American knows Singapore because that
kid that got caned now it's that stupid
movie which movie o crazy o crazy rich
Asians right right yeah I never saw that
was it good uh I didn't like it because
I don't like rom-coms oh and like come
on the premise is like a girl an
American Asian girl is like dating this
guy from Singapore he she doesn't know
he's rich and she finds out on the plane
there it's like the most [ __ ] thing
it's just conspicuous consumption
I mean it's it's got some you know the
city looks beautiful and in fact I kind
of grew up with some people that that
lived that lifestyle
but I just don't like that kind of movie
it's it's it's a chick flick a chick
flick drama you're not in the church
[Applause]